سكني يتعرض الان
للاحتراق بعد استهدافه من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بقذائف معينه اذا هو
مبنى سكني وسط منطقه مزدحمه جدا كما هو
واضح مباني سكنيه ويتم استهداف يعني شقق
في الدور ما قبل الاخير كما هو واضح وهو
الطريق التي اعتمدتها اسرائيل في
الاغتيالات السابقه لا نعرف
بطبيعه الحال المبنى يعود لمن ومن بداخل
هذا المكان الذي تشتعل فيه النيران وكيف
تم ولماذا تم استهدافه لكن الواضح انه
مبنى سكني وسط حي سكني في عماره تبدو
وسط مجموعه من المباني السكنيه الاخرى
ولا نعلم بطبيعه الحال الاثار الناتجه عن
هذا الاستهداف لكن كما نسمع من الاصوات
انها في شقه سكنيه كما يقول
استهداف اخر من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لا نعلم كيف الطبيعه الاستهداف كيف كانت
لكن كما هو واضح ان الاستهداف على نسق ما
سبق خلال الايام الماضيه من استهداف شقه
سكنيه بشكل مباشر
تشتغل فيها النيران الان كما هو واضح
هل تم اخلائها من السكان املاها هل هي من
المباني التي تم تحذير سكانها ام لا كل
هذه المعلومات لا نملكها حتى الان هل هناك
شهداء او ضحايا او مصابين ايضا لا نعلم ما
نعلمه انها شقه سكنيه في مبنى سكني وسط حي
مكتظ كما هو واضح صوره من جانب اخر
باشتعال النيران في هذا المبنى وكنا قد
نقلنا قبل قليل خبر عن مراسله الجزيره
وهذه الصور كانت عن بعد الان تتضح الصوره
مبنى سكني اخر مره اخرى وشق سكنيه اخرى
تستهدف بهذه الطريقه التي نشاهدها ولا
زالت النيران تشتعل فيها
اذا كما ذكرنا هذا هو النمط الذي
استخدمته اسرائيل في الفتره الاخيره وهو
ضرب المباني السكانيه وكما ذكرت هبه بعض
المباني يرسل لها صواريخ تحذيريه
يقول لك مساء الخير